James Comey back on Capitol Hill today
after telling lawmakers over a week ago
he didn't know couldn't remember or was
unable to recall a staggering 245 times
the former FBI director very combative
afterwards taking shots at the president
Republicans and Fox News what another
day of Hillary Clinton's emails and the
steel dossier this while the President
of the United States is lying about the
FBI attacking the FBI and attacking the
rule of law in this country at some
point someone has to stand up and in the
face of fear of Fox News fear of their
base fear of being tweets stand up for
the values of this country and not slink
away into retirement
the FBI's reputation is taking a big hit
because the President of the United
States with his acolytes has lied about
it constantly and face those lies a
whole lot of good people who watch your
network believe that nonsense
I think commis boyscout image
squeaky-clean I'm not really feeling it
anymore Greg he seems cynical and jaded
and hyper partisan to me you know I here
at my feelings I'm sad that he's scared
of me I mean but you know the fact is
this is a charade of honesty right he
said he was unable to recall something
something like 250 times before he
always talks about how he's willing to
go there and willing to talk but then
when he sits down he says nothing he's
like the guy that says sure I'll come
over and help you move but then when he
gets there all he does is drink the beer
and then eat the pizza that you paid for
but doesn't lift a finger he keeps
talking about how honest he is but he
deals in mean tweets he deals in
platitudes he deals in attack as he
thinks he's a boy scout but he's more
like a just a disgruntled pitbull
he also Jedediah talks about how the
president's trying to destroy the
reputation of the FBI the president
feels like the FBI is wronged him and
there's been a lot of bad apples at the
FBI that have resigned been demoted I've
gotten in trouble for you know lying and
and and doing all sorts of really
inappropriate things
all on the president they've kind of you
know dug their own grave to some extent
this is the guy who withheld information
from the FISA Court exonerated Hillary
Clinton before he even interviewed her
or her aides he's a joke I mean he
really he has he's the only person that
I've seen up there that has less
self-awareness than Hillary Clinton he
just has no sense that he comes off so
antagonistic takes no responsibility the
fact that when somebody asked him a
question about the FBI about whether he
felt at all responsible for its
reputation going south and he just came
flat out nope not me immediately shifted
blame to the president it's outrageous
and also think about it if a private
citizen went into one of these forums
and had to answer these questions and
gave 200 plus versions of I don't know
and I don't recall when they were
involved in two enormous scandals under
under their role as leadership that
wouldn't fly I don't understand how he
gets away with just saying he doesn't
remember and doesn't have to provide
some answers as to why he withheld all
this information with respect to the
dossier the fact that it was on verified
the fact that it was funded by the
Hillary campaign I mean there's numerous
questions that he's on the line for and
I think it's really interesting that he
chooses to instead sound like he's
running for president on the Democratic
ticket and not provide adequate answers
to people who have legitimate concerns
and one I really dislike how he went
after Fox News how dare he attack the
First Amendment in this country yeah gee
I don't think anybody in Fox News pushes
any of the president's agenda we know
you're a joke how about the truth
and I there's the thing about what you
guys are going after Comey is if Cole me
is the villain in the story I guess that
means Crump is your hero but to me Comey
is on target when he says they've been
going after the FBI they've been putting
he president Crump's diminishes the FBI
because he doesn't like what they'd been
had to say he also diminishes CIA
diminishes anybody who doesn't agree
with President Trump duh what you just
learned this that he criticizes people
yeah but I'm just saying they used to be
Republican stood on he's an
equal-opportunity criticized I just
forget it but why and this is the second
part of what Comey did today he said the
entire Republican establishment both in
the Senate and the house have just
basically laid
for Trump sake his runner has become not
the Republican Party the party of Trump
and Jim Comey says hey you need to stand
up that's why he said what he said about
Fox News I think he would have said the
same if we had a Rubio in the White
House you'd be saying it's now the party
of Rubio because because the media and
the Democrats would have focused and set
hateful things about Rubio for two years
he said well life time with the media
President Bush had a tough time with
fellow Republican said it was a
president Obama had a right now I'm with
the media right well right now there's a
movie a movie out sick Cheney right now
that is supposed to rip him to shreds
and did a terrible job because they
didn't rip him to shreds enough so that
tells you that no matter who you are as
long as you're Republican the media pop
culture Democrats are gonna hate your
guts
alright tie it up for a stance okay so
one mentions like the Comey mentions the
Republicans who aren't speaking out and
and I'm saying that the president is
wrong but what Democrats on the hill
actually said that Hillary hip was wrong
about Benghazi or which Democrats came
out and said that having a private email
server was wrong basically you defend
your team they say oh you're on a team
that's that's the way it is I think lots
of people with that email server well
they did but they didn't think they all
said it said it was no big deal
that's what they said no big deal right
so the other thing is is that president
Trump's nominee and FBI director
Christopher Rea you never see him here
the new media he's just doing his job
and I think that there's command and he
commands respect for that he's a
handsome fellow